good morning to you john hey folks and
welcome to mondays with monica i'm
pumped about this interview tlc is known
for featuring large families
and the network introduced viewers to
the doricos last summer
and this las vegas family yep their base
right here they really upped the ante
when it comes to how many kids they have
having 14 children multiple multiples
are these all your kids every last one
of them
[Music]
[Laughter]
the baby size family has become a really
big hit with fans and viewers watched
as karen and dion's many children dealt
with quarantine life
the couple is joining us live good
morning to both of you how you doing
morning
good hey guys first of all i want to say
god bless you and if he don't i will
because i don't know how
you have 14 little babies like that and
keep up with them
first of all when did you guys meet how
long have you all been
together and when did you get married
just answer all that in one one answer
[Laughter]
um i was a flight attendant we met a
nightclub club cure in detroit
and it's been how long 24 years
we met in 2001 we married in 2005
and we had our first baby in 2005 as
well
yeah all right and uh kudos to you
because i'm from detroit too so we're
gonna have to talk after the interview
but hey let's talk about this when did
you guys discover karen
because a woman knows before the man
does when did you realize that
you were naturally wired to have
multiples
oh my gosh when i was naturally uh i
think after the second set
when that is okay i i have so many
questions for you you have no idea i had
dreams about this interview okay so
the first time you had multiples was it
two three or four
tell me that the number and and go down
the line all 14.
okay so it's one to one two five
three and three good god almighty oh my
i
i'll tell you i told you i dreamt about
this i'm like how did she even survive
and karen how much do you weigh you're a
little bitty thing
a hundred pounds a hundred pounds wet
are you serious you're a hundred pounds
karen we've got to talk because my kid
is 15 years old he was nine pounds and i
swore i was not going back for a second
time
but let me ask you what
so my biggest was six pounds so maybe
that's all
gotta get a nice just oh my lord okay so
let's go into
when you got the call from tlc when did
they discover you how did all that work
out
uh there's a young lady uh the executive
producer her name is
laurie and salvi
uh she had uh she had been looking up
large families
and we had uh been printed in the las
vegas review journal
and so just coincidentally a couple days
after printing in the las vegas review
journal
she was googling saw our story reached
out to us
uh a relationship formed there and then
she then flew out here
and did what's called a sizzle reel
uh-huh and they took
april and now pitched it to various
networks and tlc was the one that was
most fitting for our family yes
absolutely that is just amazing okay
so either one of y'all y'all can jump in
here you gotta name all your children
within 15 seconds starting from the
oldest to the youngest who can do it can
you do it
derek dallas denver nico darris
diony daisy and dayton diaz dior
dawson d aaron and diver
oh my gosh
i'm telling you i am so amazed at this
okay
i got to ask the question y'all know
everybody thinking it and i got to keep
it real here
y'all thought about making an
appointment to um
you know slow down the family
that factory is in full
production girl full production wait so
what does that mean what you're saying
karen
can you say what what what are you
saying you said the factory is in full
production
what does that mean is this breaking
news you're trying to tell me something
you gotta speak soon
are you pregnant again are you ready
karen are you pregnant go ahead you can
tell us ain't nobody watching go ahead
gotta stay tuned
oh my gosh i know i'm gonna run into
y'all somewhere here in las vegas i'm so
happy y'all in vegas you have no
idea you know my stepdad uh he is one of
14.
his mother had seven kids waited seven
years had seven more
11 boys two girls um and the last set
that she delivered or the last time she
delivered was a set of twins and i
thought that was amazing
but then when i heard your story i'm
like you know what i'm surprised that
like johns hopkins hasn't tried to
do research on you or something call you
up and say hey we need to check out your
dna
both of you that's funny
that's right monica it is uh it's
amazing my mother miscarried triplets
just prior to having me
why yes yes and then there's twins on
both sides
we have twins okay yeah yeah
you guys are wired you're wired to have
multiples well listen i'm out of time i
could make this interview last for a
whole hour but we gotta go
tell everybody when you're coming up on
tlc what time we can catch you and we
want to know about that breaking news
karen
doubling down with the rico's on tlc
every tuesday airing at 10 o'clock uh
eastern time
you can uh tune in to us starting
tomorrow
we premiere tomorrow night
all right congratulations guys i'm going
to talk to you again i know it's coming
up
thank you so much for joining me this
morning i appreciate you hey folks and
don't forget catch the moj show facebook
live tonight at 7 00 p.m
imma try to get them again because i
want to know i think she might be
pregnant again y'all
maybe they should rename it tripling and
quadruplin down with the doricos
you get 10 you better claim it